Voyez les détails avec Olivier
Bachand.
- On la remarque à peine depuis
la rue, une maisonnette située
dans la cour arrière d'une autre
résidence.
JEAN-LUC GAGNON, propriétaire
- C'est extraordinaire, c'est
la tranquilité, c'est juste la
bonne grandeur pour un couple.
- Jean-Luc Gagnon et sa
conjointe ont acheté la
propriété, qui comprend les deux
maisons,viron 15 ans.
Ils ont d'abord habité dans
la plus grande, située à
l'avant, puis ont décidé
d'aller vivre dans la petite.
tage le terrain. Eux ont
l'autre côté. Nous, on a gardé
toute la lisière ici, en avant.
- La cohabitation se passe bien
avec leurs voisins.
Chacun a son intimité.- On a él,
les fenêtres. Il n'y a pas
de fenêtres de ce côté-là
et on a aménagé notre patio
dans une cour intérieure, ici.
- Pour le couple de Saint-
Lambert, c'est un projet
ite.
- On voulait avoir quelque chose
de petit, réduire les coûts,
autant de chauffage que
les taxes municipales, réduirele
la clé dans la porte pour partir
voyager.
- Ils on- Ils on- Ils on- Ils ot
entièrement rénové et agrandi
la maisonnette, qui a été
construite en 1890. C'est donces
qu'ils peuvent rester ici,
parce dans la vaste majorité
des villes du Québec,
il est interdit ou pratiquement
impossible d'aménager ce qu'on
appelle des unités d'habitation
accessoires, comme des maisons
en arrière-cour ou des logements
rattachés à un bâtiment
existant.
- Ici, on voit un garage pour
le rangement et juste à côté,
une porte d'entrée pour une
unité d'habitation accessoire.
- Mais ces logements existent
déjà sur le territoire
québécois, bien so
dans l'illégalité,
comme celui-ci, qui donne
sur une ruelle de Montréal.
EMMANUEL
directeur, Écohabitation
- Ça se passe tout sous le radar
et on croit qu'il est grandement
temps de reconnaître
le phéno non seulement
le reconnaître, mais le
permettre et le promouvoir.
- Selon lui, avec la crise
du logement et leur désir
de densification, les villes
du Québec doivent emboîter
le pas à d'autres province
où les unités d'habitations
accessoires sont autorisées.
- On parle de l'Ontario,
la Colombie-Britannique,
Vancouver, Toronto, Ottawa.
Créont des règlements,
des aideyens,yens,yens,yens,yen,
des guides, des conseillers.
- Au Québec, la Ville de Sainte-
Catherine, sur la rive sud,
est l'une des pionnières
en la matière. Elle a revu
son règlement sur les unités
d'habitations accessoires,
qui permettait uniquement
l'aménagement de maisons
intergénérationnelles.
MARIE-JOSÉE HALPIN
Ville de Sainte-Catherine
- On exigeait qu'il y ait une
porte commune ou des pièces
communes logements logements lo.
Sur 10 ans, on a eu neuf
demandes de projet, un seul
a été réalisé conformément
à la réglementation. C'était
tellemené que des gens
abandonnaient leurs projets ou
demandaient des dérogations.
- Depuis janvier, il est permis
d'ajouter un logement
ntaire à sa résidence
ou de construire une maison
dans sa cour arrière et de
la louer à n'importe qui,
pas nécessairementà un meà un m.
- L'objectif de la Ville,
c'était d'avoir... de permettre
une nouvelle forme de logement,s
à la propriété.
c'est chez vous.
- C'est justement pour cette
raison qu'Ariane Duguay et
sa mère ont déposé une demande
de permis afin de construire
un deuxième étage au bungalow
familial.
ARIANE DUGUAY
résidente de Sainte-Catherin
- Avec le marché actuel des
maisons, c'était difficile
d'avoir accès à une propriété.
- La jeune femme pourra vivre
dans son propre lo
en étant près de ses parents.
- On va avoir une entrée
commune, ensuite chacun
une porte pour rentrer à l
maison, dans nos appartements
respectifs, puis on partagera
la cour, le stationnement
et le garage.
- Et si jamais elle part,
ses parents ne seront pas pris
au dépourvu.
HUGUETTE ARSENEAU
résidente de Sainte-Catherine
- Ça serait possible de louer
à quelqu'un d'autre qui n'est
pas de la famille.
- La Ville de Granby a mis enple
il y a un an.
JULIE BOURDON
mairesse de Granby
- Pour la densification douce,
tout d'a
pour permettre une meilleure
accessibilité peut-être à des
logements à d'autres citoyens.
Ça peut servir comme revenu
d'appoint, pour héberger
un prochsoitsoitsoitsoitsoitsoit
un enfant, un parent
ou quoi que ce soit.
- Avec son nouveau code
d'urbanisme, Laval permet
nt d'ajoutnt d'ajoutnt d'ajoutnt
à une maison unifamiliale.
Longueuil lancera un
projet-pilote sur les unités
d'habitation accessoires au la .
Ce type de logement sera donc
de plus en plus présent
dans le